i always think about the fact that
you know you were one of the key writers
on the seinfeld show the legendary jerry
seinfeld show and it's not like you
write
in a room with a group of people right
you go and you write a script for jerry
do they hire you first to write a script
do they say go off will pay you and
write a script or you have to just
unspec
write a script and then submit it no
what they
did was they hired the staff and i was
lucky enough because
they didn't want people who'd worked on
sitcoms before right because larry david
felt like they would have been ruined
already by the system so they want
people who were new to riding sitcoms
and you had been a stand-up comic for
years and you had worked with jerry on
the road and blah blah blah blah jerry
was the emcee at the comic strip when i
auditioned at the comedy club who passed
me on the audition and larry david was
the mc a catcherizing star when i
auditioned is it a disappointment when
you write a killer seinfeld episode and
you don't get to be in it you know
howard it would kill me
you've written probably some of the most
legendary seinfeld episodes and yet you
walk around you know and people will go
around and of course go to jerry jerry
with love your show i love when you had
shrinkage that was my favorite episode
meanwhile you're the person who
conceived of shrinkage no but here's the
thing i mean the ideas for that episode
the hamptons came together and it was
larry david who came up with shrinkage
even though it's in my episode because
what's very important to say about
seinfeld is every writer wrote their
draft of a script right but larry and
jerry did the final pass on every single
script so the brilliance honestly that
you see out there on tv is really
filtered through them had you ever
written a script that was so perfect
that larry and jerry just said we are
not touching this masterpiece no it
never happened now that never happened
that way everybody the big thing at
seinfeld was to pitch an idea that they
liked okay if you didn't have an idea
you were out so i knew that when i went
into larry david and jerry seinfeld's
office and it was their office together
and i said okay george hires a deaf
woman
to lip read his ex-girlfriend lips from
across the room at a party so he can
find out why she broke up with him larry
would shoot up and go that's a show
we're doing that that's a show if i'm
hired to be a writer on seinfeld because
i think this is the hardest job on the
planet yeah you know you make it look
easy but it's hard how many other
writers are there there were probably
about 10 other writers when i was there
all right when you make these pitches do
you pitch your ideas in front of the
whole writing staff or do you pitch them
privately it was just to larry and jerry
and jerry and larry had an office
somewhere and they'd say carol at 10
o'clock is your pitch meeting with us or
better yet the writer would go hey can i
catch you later i want to pitch some of
my ideas so there was no office there
for you like where you sat and sat no i
did have my own office but you don't
write those at home or you yeah you mean
you have to go into some office on a lot
somewhere and do your writing for the
day but of course that's the most fun
part of it why is that fun because
you're hanging out with funny writers
all day oh so in other words they'll
help you when you write your script or
you go off and write it on your own yeah
no i mean it was you'd go and pitch
you know ideas like that like that
became um the lip reader that episode
then it became all right well tell me
about the lip reader don't leave that
episode so fast one of the ideas of that
came from my real life which i use a lot
in my writing
of where elaine pretended she was deaf
because she didn't want the car service
guy talking to her while she was in the
back seat and that always came out of
when i was gigging as a comic and the
car service guy would pick me up it was
like i want somebody who'll just leave
me alone in the back seat that is so
true right and i would always get the
yakaholic who could not pick up on the
hints of like buddy shut it down you
know so we use that that's the amazing
thing about comedy writers something
that happens every single day of our
lives you have to turn into
greatness
the everyday horrors right you have to
be an ultra sensitive human being to be
a comedy writer right everything's got
to kind of tick you off and irk you
right and what's so great about it is to
turn it into comedy is the greatest
thing ever how about the understudy
where elaine thinks the manicurists at
the korean uh nail salon are talking
about her in korean behind her back so
she brings in george's father who served
in korea who knows korean right to find
out what they're saying and sure enough
the manicurists are talking behind
elaine's back right all right well that
genesis of that is you know people
always ask what's it like being a woman
in a male dominating industry
i think the most important thing you
have to do is mine your own experience
because that's your advantage okay like
how many guys are going to pitch elaine
thinks the korean manicures are talking
about about how to back because that
happened to me every time i got a
manicure what a classic bit that was
what a classic script right you go to
the manicurist and you figure out to
bring an interpreter to find out what
the [ __ ] they're saying behind your back
i don't know i just think that's so
brilliant and then the beauty of working
on a hit show like that was i based it
on a nail place that i went to that i
still get free manicures because the
woman is thrilled we use the exterior of
her nail plates